- Il y a l'accès au fleuve
et des airs de petit village
d'un côté. Et de l'autre,
des terrains contaminés qui
attendent une nouvelle vocation.
Il y a une qualité de vie
paisible pour une population
plus âgée que la moyenne
montréalaise.
Mais aussi une multiplication
des événements violents.
- Un, l'inflation.
la santé. Trois, la sécurité.
Ce sont les trois sujets
qui reviennent immanquablement
aux portes avec les gens.
- Karine Boivin-Roy,
qui espérait être élue avec
Denis Coderre aux dernières
élections municipales, veut
passer au palier supérieur.
- Je vote pour vous!
- Vous êtes gentille,
merci beaucoup!
- Et il se chuchote que la
nouvelle caquiste a l'ambition
de ravir au Parti libéral
la circonscription Anjou -
Louis-Riel, représentée par
Lise Thériault pendant 20 ans.
KARINE BOIVIN-ROY, candidate,CAl
- Il y a des belles choses
qui s'en viennent, un nouveau
centre médical qui serait ouvert
à proximité, également
ation et la
modernisation de l'hôpital
Maisonneuve-Rosemont.
- Sur ces questions de santé,
la gestion de la pandémie
pourrait faire basculer
ces deux électrices péquistes
vers la CAQ. Ce qui les retient,
c'est un éventuel raz-de-marée
bleu poudre.
- Démocratiquement, j'aimerais
qu'il y ait de l'opposition.
J'aime pas les gens qui
sont trop en avance.
- Un peu plus loin dans l'Est...
- Moi c'est Jocelyn Desjardins,
candidat du PQ dans Pointe-aux-
Trembles.
- Oh, bien vous êtes correct.
- Il dit comprendre ceux
qui ont eu le goût de
l'aventure caquiste.
Mais il croit au retour
de ces électeurs.
JOCELYN DESJARDINS, candidat,
PQ, Pointe-aux-Trembles
- Moi, j'ai fait partie
de cette cohorte de gens
qui ont été déçus,
dans les dernières années,
du Parti québécois.
Et le Parti québécois est revenu
sur sa mission fondamentale.
Puis, je pense qu'ici,
on a un rôle à jouer
pour renverser le déclin
du français et faire en sorte
que Montréal redevienne
la ville qu'elle doit être, la
métropole française d'Amérique.
- Libérer le potentiel de l'Est,
c'est le voeu formulé à
répétition par les élus et
candidats ces dernières années.
Et sur le terrain,
les acteurs attendent encore.
JEAN-DENIS CHAREST prés. Chambre
de commerce de l'Est de Montréal
- Ça prend deux pôles
d'innovation dans l'est de
Montréal, ça nous prend
un mode de transport structurant
qui nous connecte directement
au centre-ville, et il faut
aussi accélérer la
décontamination des sols.
Il y a des sommes
qui ont été réservées,
mais là il faut l'accélérer.
- Le désenclavement du
territoire doit passer
par le futur REM de l'Est,
qui est de retour sur
la planche à dessin.
Ce jour-là, une salle comble
assiste à la présentation
d'une autre version du REM,
proposée par deux anciens
du comité d'experts.
Ils critiquent l'efficacité
du projet sur la table
en ce moment, qui ne se rend pas
jusqu'au centre-ville.
Ils suggèrent d'ajouter
ce lien en tunnel.
CHRISTIAN YACCARINI, chef de la
dir.,  Société de dév. Angus
- J'entends un appui presque
unanime. On a aujourd'hui
dans la salle tout ce qui
peut être représentatif
de l'est de Montréal,
des tables de quartier
aux entreprises privées,
des institutions d'enseignement
au CIUSSS de l'Est.
Je crois que tous les pouvoirs
politiques vont être à l'écoute.
C'est une bonne proposition.
- Le député sortant de
LaFontaine appuie cette idée
d'une connexion directe,
même si elle n'est pas chiffrée.
Mais avant les questions
de transport, celui qui espère
être réélu pour la quatrième
fois, entend d'abord agir
pour la sécurité.
MARC TANGUAY, candidat, PLQ,
LaFontaine
- Nous voulons qu'il y ait
davantage d'interventions
en amont, soutenir nos
organismes communautaires,
soutenir nos intervenantes
et intervenants de rue
qui travaillent sur le terrain
et qui viennent notamment,
notamment, diminuer
l'attractivité des gangs de rue
sur nos jeunes.
- Dans ces trois bastions
libéraux ou caquistes,
Québec solidaire et le
Parti conservateur risquent de
récolter des appuis insuffisants
pour faire pencher la balance.
Mais que ce soit avec un vent
de changement ou de continuité,
les résidents de l'Est ne
veulent plus du statu quo.
Ici Mathieu Prost,
Radio-Canada, Mon